a timeline has been put together by
Business Insider comparing the
allegations of the Trump Russia
blackmail dossier of course the dossier
put together by former mi6 agent
Christopher Steele which made all sorts
of different allegations that has been
sort of overlapped with actual events
that are publicly verified and known and
it does not look good okay so Adam
Schiff has said the congressman a
ranking member on the House Intelligence
Adam Schiff has said we now have more
than just circumstantial evidence he has
not yet revealed exactly what he's seen
or what they have but that the case is
now beyond circumstantial we're gonna go
through this when you compare the timing
of the allegations in the dossier and
the timing of real-world events it
really doesn't look good let's start
with June and July of 2016
okay and when you look at this the blue
events and if you're if you're listening
to this I'll talk you through it
blue events on the calendar or
allegations from the dossier whereas
pink events on the calendar are
allegations are actual events rather so
for example on June 20th the dossier
alleges that Donald Trump had been
cultivated by Russian officials and on
June on July 7th Carter page traveled to
Moscow to give a speech two days later
on the 9th you see Igor second and
Carter page have a secret meeting as
alleged by the dossier and of course we
know that publicly confirmed two days
prior Carter page was in Moscow two days
after the alleged meeting from the
dossier between Igor Sechin and Carter
page amendments are made to the
Republican Party's Ukraine policy it is
unexpectedly watered down again its
timing timing correlating allegations
from the Trump Russia dossier and
publicly known events and it is
suspicious to say the least
later that month in July July 19th
Donald Trump agrees to sideline Russian
intervention in Ukraine as a campaign
issue according to the dossier the
dossier says July 19th Trump said yeah
we're not going to talk anymore about
that entire thing on the 22nd wiki
publishes the first hacked DNC emails
which you could argue could be a
distraction mechanism to take away from
the fact that Donald Trump is no longer
worried about what Russia is doing in
Ukraine and then on the 27th of July
Donald Trump asks Russian hackers
publicly to pay if they want find those
30,000 Hillary Clinton emails all of a
sudden according to the dossier only
four days later the Kremlin was weighing
whether to release more information
about Hillary Clinton okay this is just
June and July let's now just to continue
our discussion look at August okay
August 12th this is a known event Roger
stone has admitted that he started
speaking to gusoff 42.0 on Twitter which
is considered to be one of the hacking
sources involved in the hacking that
took place two days later the New York
time publishes a report on Paul Manafort
alleged payments received from Ukraine
the next day August 15th this is an
allegation from the dossier Viktor
Yanukovych told Vladimir Putin that he's
been funneling kickback payments to Paul
Manafort very tidy timing here no doubt
about it
and only four days later as we know Paul
Manafort resigns two days after that
Roger stone tweeted that John Podesta
will soon be targeted let's look at
another one this is from September
September 8th we now know that been
confirmed that Attorney General jeff
Sessions and Sergey Kiss lyac met
privately in the office of Jeff Sessions
six days later on September 14th the
Kremlin confirmed according to the
dossier that kiss lyac knew of Russian
interference in the u.s. election six
days after meeting with Jeff Sessions
later that month actual events that we
know September 23rd Yahoo reported that
Carter page met with Igor Sechin in
Moscow and at the end of September
Carter page took a leave of absence from
the campaign lastly let's see a I guess
we can keep going we have time for a
couple more
October and November of 2016 Roger stone
on October 3rd tweeted that WikiLeaks
will soon release more information on
Hillary Clinton four days later on
October 7th WikiLeaks published the
first batch of hacked John Podesta
emails President Obama accused Russia of
the hacks continuing five days later on
October 12th Roger stone admitted to
having back channeled communications
with Julian Assange and on the 13th we
have the allegation from the Trump
Russia dossier that buyer's remorse was
setting in among Russian officials on
November 3rd the Russian billionaire
Dmitry Dmitry I believe it's pronounced
Ravalli EV flew into North Carolina on
the same day as Donald Trump both of
their planes were seen on the tarmac at
an airport in North Carolina on November
3rd five days later
Donald Trump won the election continuing
now as we go forward into December we
know about the Rosneft deal selling
19.5% of its shares to unknown buyers
followed the next day by Carter Page
traveling to Moscow to meet with top
managers of Rosneft this is an aspect of
the Trump Russia story that we haven't
explored in significant detail relating
to these 19.5% of shares of Rosneft and
it the timing of it with a trip by
Carter page is also very very suspect at
the end of December December 29th
President Obama issued new sanctions
against Russia Michael Flynn called kiss
Lee Act to discuss those sanctions
something initially denied by Michael
Flynn but we now know to be true and on
December 30th Vladimir Putin announced
that Russia would not be retaliating
against new sanctions that gets us to
January and February of this year
On January 10th top intelligence
officials briefed Trump on the existence
of the dossier and on January 19th the
day before the inauguration the New York
Times reported on intercepted
communications between Trump a
associates and Russians on February 13th
Michael Flynn resigned as Trump's
national security adviser which brings
us to March where we learned that
Attorney General Jeff Sessions after it
was revealed that he had at least two if
not three meetings with Russian
officials recused himself from any
Russia related investigations Donald
Trump then tweeted in what seemed like
an effort to distract from the growing
Russia scandal that Obama had his quote
wires tapped eleven days later the House
Intelligence Committee said that there
was no evidence of wiretapping
whatsoever and most recently March 20th
James Comey the FBI director confirmed
the existence of the investigation into
Trump Russia ties now what's my caveat
here Pat my caveat is if you have a very
conspiratorial mind and you say hey you
know what all the lies about when that
Trump Russia dossier was first created
and presented to John McCain it was all
lies right the dossier was retro
actively crafted to appear to fit into
publicly known events you could make
that argument however that's a pretty
wide-ranging conspiracy because we now
have so many people on record saying
that they had their hands on the dossier
months and months ago it would require
either a wide-ranging conspiracy
involving even Republicans like John
McCain or it would require a time travel
device which I don't think Republicans
have access to that is true however the
burden of proof is still on us and we
have a whole bunch of circumstantial
evidence now yeah it's kind of like the
equivalent of finding fingerprints at
the crime scene I would love to see some
direct evidence and as we heard from
ranking member Adam Schiff on the House
Intelligence Committee we seem to have
some - what's your gut on the next 10
days will there be some major Russia
revelation Adam Schiff now for a while
has been saying he's seen more than
circumstantial evidence we have seen as
a result of the chair of the Intel
committee Devon Nunez the Republican
running to the White House every time he
gets evidence seemingly that the
credibility of that panel is
aggressively being called into question
you think we'll learn anything big in
the next 10 days
I could see Nunez recusing himself it's
hard to say because I would wouldn't be
surprised
one of the trumped campaign members or
someone in his transition team or even
someone in the administration now it
comes out that they were doing something
nefarious yeah but it's just hard to
pick who would it be
it is tough I think that what may turn
this is we heard a rumor from national
security expert Juliet Cayenne she
talked about this on CNN and tweeted
about it she has she is claiming that
Michael Flynn may be testifying or
speaking to the FBI in a way presumably
to defend himself that may incriminate
others in the Trump administration I
think we may see an insider realize that
the you know what is about to hit fan
and turning yeah interesting and we know
that there are some scheduled hearings
but the problem is that their public
hearings so if Paul Manafort and Roger
stone and Carter Page decide to testify
yeah because it's a known open setting
we may not learn too much from that will
those be behind closed doors yeah and
and the there's a whole other story
involving scheduled not scheduled
scheduled and canceled hearings and
maybe we'll dig into that tomorrow but
there's a lot of back story here so
anyway that's where we are right now
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show